Her low freak bitches.
Buddhism as a religion,
I mean at least in terms of how we understand religion.
Is it tax free?
Uh,
is it tax free?
Yeah.
Do you have tax free exemption the same way that other religions too?
We personally don't.
But you could,
you could do that.
Yeah.
You'll get a fucking chase down,
don't do it.
And
it gets really,
really hairy when you don't want to pay taxes.
They go,
oh,
really?
Time to take a little closer look at the Buddhist Geek Organization.
Yeah.
I see what you're doing on Saturday nights there.
Infiltrate.
Yeah.
I think with anything like Buddhism,
I mean you inherit,
but choosing that framework we inherit all,
we inherit it.
And so there's a lot about um,
religions and spirituality in general that is not,
that I don't personally like,
you know,
so,
um,
I think that there is a,
there's a tendency to project,
I mean you brought in the word divinity,
so I'll use it like to project our divinity onto the teachers are onto some sort
of system and um,
it can be disempowering for a lot of people.
People can get trapped and beliefs that you know,
have been carried forward for,
you know,
years and centuries that aren't,
isn't forwarding anymore.
Um,
and so that sense like by choosing to go under Buddhism,
we're also choosing to,
you know,
work on how we can evolve,
how we think about it.
And one thing that I really like is the,
is the practices themselves,
um,
the mind training aspect of it.
That's what's been really beneficial to me and that's one of the reasons why
I've chosen to continue cause if its impact,
the mind training aspects of it.
Like what,
what,
what do you think is like the tangible benefits of this mind training aspect of
it that you personally experience?
Personally I can say personally I feel much,
much more,
much more open.
I'm much more generous,
compassionate.
There is a lot more freedom I can get stuck on the smaller sense of self.
Meaning,
you know,
I have these thoughts of unworthiness or self contraction or hatred or any of
those,
you know,
w biological kind of urges and at the same time they're so transient and they're
so not who I am.
And I see that very,
very clearly that it kind of diminishes in just a second.
I'm on the good days.
Sometimes it's more intense and I've learned to really work with that and learn
how to see clearly what's happening so that I have the freedom to really choose
how to live my life in a much more full way.
That just the evidence that the Internet is real.
That is one of the best evidence is that there are people that are just so far
beyond how fucking smart you think smart is.
It's like remember when you were like five or six years old,
you had like a lot of times you had like this one kid in the neighborhood that
maybe it was like a little bit bigger,
a little bit stronger than the other kids and when you would play with them on
the field,
like he'd get like bummed out.
Like you get knocked over and shit like remember what you thought that was like
that was a strong little kid.
But if you were there right now,
you'd be like,
get out of here.
You little fuck,
fuck knocking in everybody,
you know.
You know what I mean?
I,
it was more secured that he had freckles or something like that.
Yeah.
He'd be like,
get out he fucking little Weirdo.
Don't be mean to me.
I'm a grown ass man.
But that's what I feel like,
like technologically and,
and just the mental capacity of a super genius in comparison to me.
I feel like if I'm that little kid and like if I tried to figure out how the
fuck they figured out the Internet,
I just be like,
oh my brain isn't worked out good.
I can't talk to you.
You're freaking me out man.
You know,
if you,
if you went into one of those dudes offices and they have those crazy like
goodwill hunting shit on the wall and he's doing those equations that fucking
nobody understands,
you know,
that they'll work on for years.
You know,
even the professor didn't like,
how did you,
what does fuck yeah.
I remember like in goodwill hunting the fucking dumb,
the janitor fixes the problem.
Then leave it open to the janitor can work on the problem.
Really?
Yeah.
What if he just erased it?
What if he's just crazy?
He's not.
Why you had channeled her bitch,
this is a stupid story.
Here's a super genius.
Janitor it.
Get the fuck Outta here.
You're smarter than anybody.
You can figure out these equations and nobody else can.
And you're also beautiful.
What are the odds and charming.
It's just so wacky,
wacky.
So I see we could spend the whole thing talking about this because it's so,
it's one of those things where like,
there's a bunch of people in on a joke,
you know,
and you're like,
just wanting someone to say,
okay,
we're just fucking,
and no one does.
You know what I mean?
Well,
those belief systems,
the thing about having those belief systems is that they're very empowering for
people who believe in him.
Like if you,
if you look at it and go,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Fucking planet.
Xenu really insane.
Like I'm reading about this after you brought up Excalibur while you were
talking about it,
and I pulled up that website,
that mock Scientology,
z new.net.
Oh,
I've never been there.
But this,
oh my favorite site.
Right.
They have everything they have,
they have the entire Scientology like,
like Whoa,
everything about what they believe.
All of the operating manual.
I grabbed everything,
wiki leaks and wasn't looking at that is operating the operating Payton's manual
like level three,
which is apparently where I guess Tom Cruise is like four or five or six or
something.
But he was three a couple years.
Like they have different manuals,
you know,
so he was three a couple of years ago and now he's four or five or six.
I don't know where he's at and I haven't been keeping up with his level what
rank is at,
but I know he's ranked up because they've like given him,
they made up some new ward for him.
Did you ever see that video that leaked?
Yeah,
he's like using all this stuff that was like,
they made up this one,
they made up this thing they'd never had.
It was a guardian of the galaxy,
kind of like gave it to him and he was like,
he's like saying all that shit that made no sense.
And using all their words and stuff.
Yeah,
the Internet and people putting music to it and she had gorgeous.
Yeah.
It's so good to work of art.
It is.
Man.
Doesn't mean almost.
It is almost like something that you would,
you'd see from some artists who's doing so I'm like fucking piece.
Yeah,
know where he's going.
Oh Man.
That'd be so brilliant if like he just all of a sudden flipped and told
everybody.
Yeah,
I've been just listening.
It helps my acting if I can pretend to really be into Scientology,
but this long it's like the dumb and dumber me,
the new one coming out.
It'd be seen the before.
No,
no.
I have,
oh my God.
It's genius.
But there's like a,
there's like a whole thing where Jim Carey Garinger is Carrie.
Carrie Carrie's character is like in an insane asylum.
Go over this over that chick.
The Mary Samsonite has it gone from the first one and then it turns out he was
like joking like for like 20 years and yet Lloyd Lloyd,
you mean to tell me that you've been,
you've been faking for 20 years,
all for a gag.
And he's like,
Yup.
It's like,
that would be amazing if he did that.
Okay.